it's hard to deny that we currently live
in a gta 5 gta online obsessed world the
games now spain across three console
generations and i'm honestly shocked
there hasn't been a port for switching
mobile yet don't even think about it
rockstar however no matter how many new
shiny versions of michael franklin and
trevor we get i'll still have a special
place in my heart for the man that came
before them gta 4's protagonist nico
bellick but what exactly is it about
nico that makes him stand out could it
be his sense of fashion his bowling
skills or maybe i just prefer playing as
one character in a gta game let's dive
deeper into who nico is and why he's
still a well-designed character 14 years
after he first toured through the
streets of liberty city
[Music]
everybody loves a good underdog story
right well when you break it down gta 4
is just that nico was born into a very
poor family and was forced to fight in
the yugoslav wars as a teenager he was
witness to many war crimes and most
likely committed some himself if that
wasn't enough he lost his second family
of sorts when most of his squad was
betrayed by one of their own being one
of only three survivors of the attack
nico became obsessed with finding the
traitor and getting revenge
i know the traitor was not me
so for ten years
i've been searching for the other two
one of them leaves here
why are you telling me this now do you
always get sentimental after you kill
people
you kept asking the poor guy was on a
steady losing streak that didn't get
much better after the war unable to find
a job nico fell into human trafficking
work in order to get by and i know i
know only a monster would smuggle and
sell other human beings so that last
point isn't really helping me sell him
as a great character but stick with me
because i believe that deep flaws like
that is what helped make nico more
believable we'll get to that in a second
following a bot's smuggling run neagle
joined the merchant navy to escape
russian crime boss ray balgren this in
turn led to his decision to head to
america where he thought he could start
fresh with his wealthy cousin roman in
reality roman was broker than the
district he lived in and america proved
to be just as crime infested as other
places in the world nico played the
cards he was dealt tried to reshuffle
but ended up with the same hand in a new
city rockstar made a deeply flawed
character with a troubled past and made
me believe that he was a guy down on his
luck looking for change i wanted so
badly for him to have at least one win
even if he technically didn't deserve it
because deep down we all want to believe
in second chances unfortunately for nico
that second chance was harder to achieve
thanks to three of his key motivating
factors money family slash loyalty and
revenge each time nico accepts a new
mission throughout the story one or more
of these factors lie behind his decision
to say yes and just like his flaws that
i hinted at earlier knowing nico's why
is another way that rockstar makes him
believable
a well-crafted character fits into their
story well leaving very little doubt in
the audience that they belong there nico
not only fits into liberty city but he
also feels very grounded in our real
world as well he's numb depressed angry
cynical and sarcastic he suffers from
ptsd and his worldview is based on all
of the horrors of his youth so you don't
question why he's agreeing to go against
standard morals you know his flaws and
motivation i believe that when nico
worked for vlad at the start of the game
because i knew that roman was in trouble
and nico was motivated by family and the
same goes for when niko ended vlad's
life he saw how the lone shark had
affected roman emotionally and wanted
revenge he had no problem pulling the
trigger because he felt his reason was
justified and being a bit numb from past
events murder doesn't have the same
effect on him as it does on roman who
rightfully freaks out the entire car
ride to vlad's fate it's depressing as
hell but it makes sense rockstar could
have made a crime game about a fish out
of water character adjusting to a new
city but instead they made nico an onion
with layers that are slowly peeled back
throughout the game his vulnerability
depth and backstory led me to believe
him more which led me to like him more
which led me to sympathizing with him
even though i've never experienced his
crime related struggles it also helps
that nico also showed more remorse at
times than some other characters we meet
throughout the game like in one
conversation when nego explained that he
wishes he could forget things he did in
the war and then immediately adds that
he wishes he could forget his actions in
liberty city as well or this scene with
faustin's wife that sealed the deal and
sold me on nico's inner conflicts life
is complicated i
i never thought i'd live like this
no when the war came i did bad things
after the war i thought nothing of doing
bad things
i killed people smuggled people
sold people
and you don't worry about your soul
after you walk into a village
and you see 50 children all sitting
neatly in a row against the church wall
each with their throats cut and their
hands chopped off
you realize that the creature that could
do this
doesn't have a soul nico seems to be a
neutral evil anti-hero and one way that
rockstar makes him easier to accept as
such is by having him follow his own
basic set of morals that other criminals
around him may not adhere to let's use
faustin for this example the man is an
unpredictable loose cannon that has no
code meanwhile nico has a method to his
madness he follows orders like he's been
trained to since he was young and seems
to need a good reason before killing
someone even if that reason is something
as small as an unpaid debt he goes
polite and kind to those who are the
same to him he says no to offers of
drugs and alcohol use and he isn't going
off on a rampage just for the hell of it
sure the game's open nature allows you
to take niko on killing sprees during
free roam but we're just talking about
the main story here the situations that
rockstar planned for nico to be in
everything adds up to a character that
feels genuine i still get the feeling
that nico is someone that i've bumped
into and luckily didn't get on the bad
side of as i roam the streets of new
york city throughout the years it also
helps that rockstar nailed the vibe of
manhattan and its surrounding barrels
gta 4 as a whole has a washed out color
palette and a gritty tone that makes it
feel like an nyc crime drama instead of
an overly satirical action-packed heist
flick nico never felt like a caricature
of an eastern european man and i think
that goes a long way to making him more
believable and well written
and finally i'm a huge sucker for
sarcasm and nico has a great dark
sarcastic humor i kick all the asses
that play me they call me the janitor
because you can't pay your debts and
they make you mop the floor
fertile man's cousin
what's your name again big mouth blick
very catchy sit down
may not be the best example of a great
human being but i think he's a great
example of a well-written character with
many layers rockstar was effective at
making the player care about him roof
for him but also hate him just enough so
that they don't feel like a horrible
human being themselves hit the comment
section let me know what you think about
nico or which gta character you think is
well written and why
[Music]